all right so President Obama said that
Americans need to vote in November
because our democracy depends on it okay
what I'm about to say may shock some
people he's right
this November election is more important
than any midterm in our lifetime the
stakes they couldn't be higher
Democrats have proven again and again
they will do anything say everything and
anything to get their power back to make
sure even the Donald Trump fails no
matter how much it hurts the country we
cannot let this happen
now today President Obama tried to
actually take credit for the economic
successes we're now seeing it's not true
but we'll show it to you when you hear
how great the economy is doing right now
let's just remember when this recovery
started
I'm glad it's continued but when you
hear about this economic miracle that's
been going on when the job numbers come
out monthly job numbers and suddenly
Republicans are saying it's America I
had to kind of remind them actually
those job numbers are the same as they
were in 2015 and 2016 actually fake news
you didn't build that
now let's remind Obama about the economy
left remember
under his watch 95 million Americans out
of the labor force thanks to President
Obama's stellar leadership we had the
lowest labor participation rate since
the 70s we now have the highest we had
the lowest homeownership rate in 51
years Obama eight years of Obama 13
million more Americans on food stamps
eight million more Americans in poverty
we now have four million fewer Americans
on food stamps four million new jobs
under him anemic growth endless
burdensome regulation the lowest
consumer confidence that was the Obama
economy and he took on more debt than
every other president before him
combined he can spin it any way he wants
but we the American people are smart
enough not to believe the fake news that
he was trying to feed us today now
President Trump actually responded to
Obama's outrageous claim as he tried to
claim victory when he was a failure
watch I think he was time to take some
credit he was trying to take credit for
this incredible thing that's happening
to our country if the Democrats could
and I have to say this to President
Obama and it wasn't him but would have
been the same thing if the Democrats got
in with their agenda in November of
almost two years ago instead of having
4.2 up
I believe honestly you'd have 4.2 down
you'd be negative you'd be in negative
numbers
you'd be a negative number the Atlanta
Fed right now is predicting 4.7% GDP
growth with the third quarter Obama also
took shots at the president's foreign
policy while ignoring his own blunders
during his tenure in the White House
let's see Iran and I'll have more
flexibility
tell metell Putin take a look they're
undermining our alliances closing up to
Russia what happened so the Republican
Party now Trump has been tougher on
Russia than Obama ever was remember was
Obama basically the one guy that ignored
Russia's power grab remember Ukraine
member Crimea it was Obama who allowed
Russia to prop up Assad the Syrian
dictator gassing his own people Obama
gave Clinton the reset button how dumb
that was remember he was promising all
have more flexibility after the election
tell Vladimir I wanted to present you
with a little gift which represents what
President Obama and Vice President Biden
and I have been saying and that is we
want to reset our relationship
[Music]
150 billion two Iranian mullahs by the
way expressed his admiration for his
friends and allies in the mainstream
media which shouldn't surprise us they
helped push through Obama's radical
agenda they never held them accountable
it was a love fest from day one he was
the anointed one they gave him a pass
for hanging out with oh let's see
Bill Ayers Bernardine Dohrn that's where
he started his political career make
excuses 20-plus years in the pews of
mister GD America and America's chickens
have come home to roost and it shouldn't
shock anybody that Obama's going to
defend his media friends but once again
today Obama he still can't stop taking
shots at Fox can't help himself take a
look it shouldn't be democratic or
republican to say that we don't threaten
the freedom of the press because they
say things are published stories we
don't like
[Applause]
I complained plenty about Fox News but
you never heard me threaten to shut him
down or call them enemies of the people
actually more fake news Hannity history
lesson Obama took multiple shots at Fox
News this show in particular during his
presidency and since Obama seems to have
a blind spot in his memory we've got the
tape to remind them take a look I'll put
out put mr. Burgess up against Sean
Hannity they'll tear them up I mean look
is Sean Hannity suddenly gonna get on
the air who is and say you know I was
wrong about this Obama guy he's my man
no that's not gonna happen
I think that there's a certain segment
of hardcore Sean Hannity fans that
probably wouldn't want to go have a beer
with me there's no doubt about that if
you watch Fox News on a regular basis it
is a constant menu they will find like
folks who make me man I don't know where
they find him I wasn't viewed through
this prism of Fox News and conservative
media and making me scarier he wind the
whole time
and by the way what a mr. Burgess to
tear me up Wow Obama did target Fox News
as well as an office here's an example
2009 the Obama White House they tried to
exclude Fox News from a press poll
interview with an administration
official 2013 the story broke that the
Obama DOJ under the leadership of yeah
mr. holder they actually spied on one of
our reporters at the time James Rosen
they looked through Rosen's phone calls
and his emails from 2009 while
attempting to find a source for one of
Rosen stories so what you heard from
Obama today was nothing more than fake
news and liberal spin this is why this
midterm election is so important he's
right about one thing it's important I
can't stress enough yeah a lot in the
countries at stake Democrats win in
November you stay home well this is
what's gonna happen and worse in the tax
cuts they want their crumbs back that's
right Nancy Pelosi calls them crumbs and
she wants them back
and that's the money in your paycheck
that will be gone they want to impeach
President Trump it's not a secret
Chuckie Schumer openly admitted it just
this past week
here's him in his own words
they want to impeach it but they try not
to say it and then of course they want
to keep Obamacare how did that work out
keep your doctor keep you planned pay
less not very well this week we saw just
how low they'll stoop to block a Supreme
Court pick a president Trump Democrats
want what to abolish ice they want open
borders they will kill off every single
deep state investigation that's going on
right now and that'll be investigating
Donald Trump from now until the cows
come home